good evening welcome to planning West my
name is Justin carriage I'm the chair of
the committee in front of me are the
other members councillors members of the
committee and either side of me are the
council officers who help us make our
decisions and if I can ask them to
introduce themselves
Olivia Quinn committee services Ross
chambers legal services my name is
Richard Gardner I'm the planning manager
in my role tonight as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
unbound by the code of Professional
Conduct to the Royal Town Planning
Institute and planning committee members
are not bound by the case offices
recommendation or by oral advice thank
you still Aarthi planning officer Eddie
wrench senior planning officer lovely so
if we go to the agenda item 1 apologists
for absence apologies from councillor
Giles who canceller building a
substituting for oh and councillor for
jury as well yes thank you who has sent
his apologies to any disclosures of
interest councillor Perry I'm sorry
absol organ Thank You chairman first of
all application 1802 276 I've received
communications via email which properly
everyone has and secondly item 1803 3 3
1 ful this application the site is
within my ward however I come here to
the meeting with an open mind to the
application thank you great yes I think
everyone has received emails Carol
Richards thank you yes I have received
emails on first item and
also the fun lights and traffic sports
club I was a member of the sports club
I'm no longer and I'm here with an
entirely open mind okay thank you and I
made representations against the
application 25a Ulster Road so I will be
sitting out on that and because it's the
village I live in I'm going to sit out
on the next one as well the old post
office in Sanborn which I think brings
us to the need to elect a chair for
tonight as we don't have our deputy
today there's a proposal counselor and
power proposed cancer Richards thank you
seconder for that
I'll take cancer fielding are there any
other proposals no okay so all those in
favor thank you so let's get straight on
with it and do that
okay Thank You members we will go
straight to it in that case so this is
application 1802 276 ful 25a Ulster Road
in studly and I'm presenting opposite
Thank You chairman good evening this is
a full play application for the change
of use of a former Bank to oppose hot
food take away the proposed development
will also include a new shop front of
ventilation extraction system to the
rear and other associated works this
application site is within the village
center subtly as illustrated by the
black dots on this plan to the east of
the Ulster Road here we see an aerial
view of the application sites signified
by an arrow here we have the submitted
site location plan which shows the
application site in its entirety here we
see the proposed front and rear
elevations there is then a zoomed in
image on this slide which shows
specifically the front elevation one can
see the shopper in detail that's
proposed in addition to indicative
signage that would be subject to a
separate vertical application were
permission to be granted for this
application alterations to the shop
front include amongst others the
redecorating of the existing brickwork
to an off-white color from the existing
darker brick and the incorporation of an
aluminium shop front with a new door and
glazed elements on the ground full level
here we see a zoomed in image of the
rear proposed rear elevation backing
onto an existing car park area this
includes details of amongst other things
the of an extraction Dutch here the
Museu seemed an image of the proposed
ground floor element we now have some
photos of a site and its surroundings
here we are standing in on the opposite
side of the ostrich immediately in front
of the application building itself here
sits slightly to the north or the
application site looking south eastwards
to see the unit in relation to the rest
of the Ulster Road and similarly from
this side we can see we're sitting a
slightly
Southie application site looking down
hill in a northeast which direction here
we have stood in the carpark to the rear
of the operation building looking
westwards towards the rear elevation and
also the rear elevation of the rib the
rear of other buildings in the vicinity
on the austere Road and finally here we
are stood closer to the rear elevation
but won't we see the current state of
the site that concludes my presentation
chair please refer to your update sheets
for details of the briefing note that
has been circulated to all members last
yesterday evening chairman the
recommendations to grant this
application for the reasons that aren't
pages 13 and 14 of your agendas thank
you thank you very much members you have
you had enough time to read your update
sheet and it's quite a short one for
this application are you happy for us to
move straight two speakers yes okay in
that case our first speaker is the
passion Town Council's mr. Paul bloom
please come up now counselor this is not
your first time so you know the drill
three minutes from when you start and
I'll give you a 30-second warning Thank
You chair councillors we've been here
before
I think the parish council has put a
really good explanation of why this
particular application should be reviews
and I apologize I sent information out
today but I took the page numbers and
the page numbers on the document I've
got were not the ones that I wanted to
send you I've been from walk along the
Ulster Road today from the Barley Mow
less than half a mile in that walk I
counted 11 out of 30 units are actually
fast-food or takeaway or both so well
over or just over 30% of the existing
businesses on that road are fast-food
takeaways and that gives you an
indication of one of the reasons why in
the survey in the parish council what
the neighborhood planning team was just
published
we've just had all the results back in
that 82 percent of residents answered
want to encourage a more diverse
of retail outlets 86% want to see
additional service outlets such as banks
visitors estate agents and officers of
accommodation 85% actually said there
were too many fast-food takeaways in the
village that is that ties in with the
parish plan that we have and is on
record with District Council and it is
forming the information that we need
when the neighborhood plan does get
published one of the things we will be
pressing there is the fast food
takeaways are refused because the
problem they have is that the majority
of them are nighttime economy we have a
village that we're very lucky we can
have an approximately another 500 people
a week coming into the village from the
new study Castle development what's
going to happen is they're going to walk
up into the village and find that most
of the premises that are takeaways are
shut they turn around and walk back that
is a real distraction from what could
happen in the village if they were
actually shot so people could go and
ever moved around and have a look around
and see what's going on it is very easy
to prevent offers coming in for retail
outlets all you need to do is push the
rent up a little bit and I was
interested so I think one of the claims
is that it's not been nobody has been
interested I would suggest that that may
be because they are the risking too much
for it or it wasn't actually advertised
to the extent Lee it could have been
there are many other outlets that have
opened up the one application that is
referred to 30 seconds in HSBC Bank
where that was overturned by the
inspector when this committee refused
that that is now laying empty since the
alterations there so even when it gets
permission there is nobody willing to
take it up and actually open them so we
really think that this is something that
should be refused for the reasons given
in the parish councils response thank
you very much thank you members do have
any questions
can safari thank you good evening good
evening I just wonder whether you could
just expand a bit on the impact of the
character of the high street that this
particular application would have I
think the issue we have is that people
when they go shopping know the high
street as we all know is on its last
legs and wherever you go so what you
want are outlets that attract people
come in the the curiosity shops the
little knick-knack shops or cafes that
are open during the daytime one can
offer something different something
special if this was a cafe that was
offering he was open from first thing in
the morning tonight no problem but pizza
it's you come in you grab and you go and
that is the problem you're looking for
people to come and spend time in the
village and when they're spending time
they're spending money and that helps
all the other outlets at the same time
okay council fielding proposed to what
the shop the shop yeah so the left-hand
side is a former post office it is now
an office I think it's accountants and
that type of business and there is a
flat up above it to the other side is
one of the other hairdressers say 68% of
the residents in the village said there
was too many hairdressers as well but we
have what we've got then you've got the
lucky host Joe Chinese takeaway okay
members if there are no further
questions councillor thank you very much
your contribution thank you cancers so
we have no list of objectives to speak
so we'll move straight to our applicant
which is mr. roberts mr. roberts if
you'd like to come forward is it
pronounced Ossian now
okay so you've got three minutes if you
press the button in the middle it'll
light up I'll give you a 30-second
warning if you say cz for questions
afterwards that'd be great so as soon as
you're ready thank you very much
my name is option roberts and i'm
principal planner DPP the agents for the
application i don't wish to add too much
the officers report nor the briefing
notes we circulated yesterday but there
are one or two points that would like to
address following the bank's closure in
2016 the unit has contributed absolutely
nothing to the local economy and
detracts from the character and
appearance of the center the reuse of
the unit will therefore bring
significant improvements both
economically and visually it is evident
from the report before you that concern
remains about the balance of uses within
the center this was dealt with in some
detail by the inspector for the hidden
house appeal down the road in discussing
this very issue
the inspector comments that the adverse
effect on a mix of services on retail in
the village has been overstated and are
outweighed by the benefits of bringing
this empty unit back into use as
outlined in a note these comments were
made on the false understanding that
there were 15 takeaways in the centre
accordingly given that there are in fact
only nine units operating solely as
takeaways in the centre we are of a firm
view that the proposed change would
increase the range and choice for local
people and would not adversely affect
the mix of uses furthermore the proposed
change is being brought forward by the
future operator rather than the landlord
and therefore the benefits would be seen
immediately rather than the unit sitting
vacant for a further period of time
waiting for an occupier
it's also worth mentioning that there's
also PD permitted development rights to
change back to class a1 retail or class
a2 financial services in terms of the
buyer benefits these include job
creation 30 jobs will be created and of
these more than 90 percent of employees
will be sourced locally
the wages from which would of course be
spent locally
as well appearance to the center a
changes proposed would materially
enhance the appearance of the unit by
opening it out onto the high street
opening hours the proposed use will
operate from 11:00 a.m. until late at
night meeting meaning that the frontage
would be active throughout the day
increasing footfall the use would
attract people into the center to the
benefit of other local businesses and
then charity focus Domino's encouraged
their operations to be part of their
local communities through contributions
to local events and charities finally
it's also important to note that there
are no technical objections respect of
noise odor and highway safety first in
conclusion we believe that when looking
at the overall planning balance the
Dominus proposed investment in devote
and development is sadly is very much in
line with the local and national
policies and I would therefore
respectfully request that the
application be approved thank you thank
you very much any questions for fielding
organization that takes food to the
customer where would you be parking the
bikes or and will that be sorry do you
know what sort of percentage of the
customers will be people who get
deliveries it's it varies from store to
store but we generally see around 75%
will be delivered about 25% collected
collection and delivery and the public
is there any way is the plenty around a
park and he's on a main road yeah this
is for the delivery vehicles at the rear
of a store there is a large car parking
area and then this there this is a local
center and therefore it's considered to
be a sustainable location the delivery
ones won't be coming won't be on the
main road no they'll be able to park at
the rear of the store
no I have a question if I may you
mentioned 2016 is when the financial
services business closed and it's been
unoccupied since then what's been done
to market that building for similar use
in that time it's it's been continually
marketed by this by local agents the the
hidden house appeal as well was marketed
in a similar way and again the inspector
found that the marketing was sufficient
I would also point out that the tech
area or your local policies do not
require the marketing to have taken
place to let permit the change of use in
this circumstance but something has
taken place that's my thanks and you
said at 11 a.m. till late save me going
through my papers again what does late
means 11 o'clock lovely okay councils
any other questions council fielding the
estimated number of people who lead in
have you gotten done any marketing on
that if it's difficult to know there are
on this one some barstools so there are
some seats in in the window so there
will be an element of people being able
to sit inside and there their pizzas in
terms of numbers again I I don't know
that I figure I'm afraid I don't know
okay I think I think that's it so thank
you very much okay thank you very much
that's pretty good so counts the
carriage if you would like to come
forward you get five minutes and as you
well know thank you I don't love to say
I'm not going to use more but I normally
do I just want some stock however you
already thank you very much
listening to - to that I can't really
disagree with any of the the benefits
which have been put forward the will be
benefit would be benefits to this
proposal however I think it shows that
the level of concern residents myself
and the parish council have
when when we see those those possible
benefits coming from the reuse of a
building of whatever type of use but we
still do not think it's at all
appropriate or good for the village to
have another take away there so even
though all of these possible benefits we
still think it's worth keeping it there
allowing it to be used at some point in
the future for something which isn't a
take away now this was here before us
before you a year ago the reason who's
come back is because of the appeal of a
similar application which again this
committee turned down but was granted an
appeal at the Hayden house one the old
HSBC Bank which is now granted as a take
away
so obviously we come back here to say
well let's not bother going to appear
let's just get it get it granted so that
is a change between now and when this
committee refused it last time and that
is there's been a peel decision against
a very similar application so I can see
how that might sway your mind and you
should definitely bear that in mind
obviously but that's not the only thing
that's changed because of that Appeal
decision the old HSBC Bank the Hayden
house site has been renovated and is
open for offers as a take away but it
has not been taken up it is empty there
is an empty space brand-new waiting for
a tenant and I'd love Domino's pizzas to
take that actually it would be perfect
this parking it's it's it's a great
company and it's already got take away
license or or a a5 usage but that is
empty you know one of the one of the
main reasons that the appeal was granted
in favor of that that application was
that here's an empty building it's
better to have a takeaway than an empty
building okay and we've still got an
empty building okay but it's got a take
away license
so I think that's one of the reasons
which has been shown in in retrospect in
hindsight to be well okay we can we can
not read off as a reason
another thing that's happened since we
last you last went against refused this
application is we've had guidance from
our policy team our planning policy team
has put out with supplementary planning
document development requirements with
an H for is the particular section which
deals with hot food takeaways this is
our professionals giving giving us
advice on how to interpret our core
strategy now at the moment it's out for
consultation I'm sure you'll be told
what it's out the consultation has not
been adopted
however the consultation document is
prepared by our planning policy officers
these are the people who are in charge
of our planning policy and how it
evolves and this is their opinion on
what our planning policy actually means
and I'm sure you've read what what I
sent to you earlier and what is in the
consultation document about how we
should be very concerned about the
preponderance of takeaways detracting
from the otherwise vibrant and varied
nature of our Heights troops I think
I'll stop there and if there are any
questions please go ahead throughout
there are policy numbers I think CS 23
CS one CS 22 which which have documented
in various places I'll stop
thank you members accounts filling how
many empty shops are there in the high
street
well if we take the Ulster Road as High
Street in this case I think this is the
well there's the empty shop which has
permission thought for take away so
that's one there's this one which is
another and there's another takeaway
restaurant which is empty at the moment
so we have three out of about so it's
probably the takeaway restaurants as a
vacant at the moment with a restaurant
well yes all of them in fact yes Thank
You chairman the draft emerging SPD hot
food takeaways part H suggests in here
that there is consideration should be
given to what proportion of a five use
to other a uses would be appropriate but
we don't have a figure for that is there
a figure attached to the draft document
you know no there isn't
there are figures in that draft document
about what proportions we have at the
moment and obviously it's there's a list
of all the the main rule centers given
and Stratford
for instance steadily comes out the
highest we have fourteen let's say
takeaways and restaurants that do take
away because we only have nine
absolutely only takeaways but 14
restaurants that do take away in
takeaways out of 74 commercial
properties so that gives us 80 percent
of those on our restaurant or restaurant
or takeaways compared to wells born for
instance which is 3 percent ship stone
which is 4 percent henley which is 3
percent so you know we're at 18 percent
a lot of the other places about 3 or 4
percent which i I think shows what may
be a an appropriate level might be thank
you I think we can probably if you want
more clarity with
technical questions yeah we'll do that
and then it'll become Safari thank you
um can you also talk to me about the
steadily perish plan which is adopted
does it have anything to say on the mix
in the high street do you know it does
just so this no we're not talking about
the neighborhood plan now which which
which the parish council talked about
preceding that was the parish plan and
in that of gosh yes it did say very much
that the general feeling was that there
were too many takeaways in the village I
haven't got the exact wording here but
that was definitely unfortunately though
to be fair the the the planning of
stated that yes the the villagers didn't
want takeaways but they also didn't want
empty shops which was one of his reasons
for for granting the appeal however the
neighborhood questionnaire which has
just come out has backed out that I
think twofold we're now at eighty
percent of the population who doesn't
want takeaways Thank You chair I'm just
in by the way well spawns curry place
burnt down so whip we're down to one one
takeaway in wells born so we've got even
even less than you you suggested to then
we've got two places out out of all that
takeaways that you've got have you got
any are any other units providing a
pizza type of menu I've just heard - yes
we've definitely got one got mono
Mario's pizzas we've also got one on the
actual real high street which is just
off the VA Road which does Peters and
kebabs and things so there's two
yeah there's definitely two two places
that do peaches one that specializes in
it I mean it's not it's not dominoes but
it is it is pizza members any any more
questions I have one family
you mentioned the MT building versus not
to buy building you've got one at the
road where obviously we can't negotiate
or discuss any form of commercial
arrangements that have already been put
in place clearly you've got someone in
the form of Domino's seeking to
rejuvenate this building and occupy it
would you not rather see that building
occupied than in its current form that
that's the crud but really is the crux
of our argument but I absolutely want to
see it occupied but by by continually
granting permission to change of use two
takeaways it means that that every
building on this high street is you know
it's a domino effect hardened upon the
rents are high takeaways can sustain
that kind of rent
I know interested in taking properties
on the high street and have looked at
for instance the hayden house the one
before it became my takeaway but the
rents were prohibitive and therefore
although it was marketed on I'm
surprised I'm surprised to hear that
there were no takers because I know
there were takers for that but they
couldn't afford the rent but a take away
joint can afford the rent and you do it
for the HSBC so then okay oh oh well
actually let's try it for this Bank and
oh oh well actually maybe we could ask a
bit more rent and get it for this you
know we're getting into too much for the
commercial side that we as a planning
committee so what so assets or question
I think you've answered it yes thank you
are there any other questions council
are consider the public have objected to
it I see
yeah that there are quite a number of
houses within that vicinity and even 11
as a proportion from stuttley is very
small but do you have any idea of the
number of people on the voter's well
within the vicinity of the proposal and
in particular as shown on page 15 of the
application I can only assume that
there's two people living either side so
that would be four who would be sort of
directly affected by it and may well
have complained about it but I think
generally you'll find that there is a
there is a feeling against more
takeaways in the village as a whole so
it's not necessarily going to be the
people who came from who live next door
to it
Thank You members I last called
questions are we all done marvellous
okay can secure thank you very much so
members now we will move to clarity from
offices so you'll have any questions to
our offices cancer power yes I wonder
whether we could just have a little bit
of clarity on the significance of weight
we can give in terms of the impact of
the character of the high street from a
planning reason perspective please just
clarify so in terms of character and
appearance or is that incentive yeah
character the character on the land and
the impact on the high street scene I
would just like some greater clarity
from a material planning reason and the
weight that would have well to answer
your question that is clearly a big
consideration for offices it's been
detailed hopefully clearly in the
reports obviously after first
considering matters of principle the
matters of character and appearance are
very much of significant material
weights in offices consideration how
will the proposed alterations to the
frontage will how it sits in the high
street setting as you've touched on how
it
relates to the wider area that's very
much of a significant material
importance for us is we're making
decision for this cancer building did
you signal can you put your microphone
on please
show the site plan showing the entrances
into the carpark and how where the exit
is
from the propose to shop into the
carpark
in answer to your question counselor
there's no direct route for the public
from that that rear car park there I
need to point there's no from the put
for the public from that rear car part
they would have to go around Bell Lane
and round to the front or around the
southerly route to gain access to it if
that's where they parked is the others
in the other road at the entrance to the
public entrance is obviously on the
western front Achon to Ulster Road right
and it's a fairly narrow road you can
see the sort of width you're talking
about that and so where is the exit out
of the building then for the public it's
white never from the back for taking the
food fast food out there's no public
access from the rear so how are they
going to take the fast food out to the
rear if the vehicles are part of there
if there's two types of customers the
customer who will who will come in off
the high street there and will access
the front door on the western elevation
I'm thinking of the employees who taking
pizzas out which is what Domino's my
understanding is that they would use the
eastern elevation so there's a staff
door effectively as is common with these
uses and they would leave via the the
rear car park for deliveries okay sorry
unless you have any other questions
anyone else questions for offices and
we're all good okay in that case let's
open up to debate who would like to go
first
councillor Vance
well whatever sphere that song we refuse
to take away and I was I suppose a bit
rude in the respective I did say I don't
think the people are suddenly can cook
which went round the internet all that
whatever it is Facebook and ever in
exactly the same situation really the
reasons in my eyes solid reasons for
refusal in the respect of the aspect of
where it is and the parking and
economics is not a planning thing that
we have to look at but there is
obviously emotion from the parish
council and from the ward member to
refuse the application I'm only too
happy to go with their thoughts but my
personal opinion like the last time
although I refuted last night I proposed
refusal and we lost I think we might
lose again so those are my thoughts okay
thank you anyone else wants contributed
so I've just reflected on my answer to
councillor fielding lead committee I
suggested that all deliveries would be
through the rear in my experience is
actually quite possible that some would
also be through the front if they parked
elsewhere so that could use the front so
I think my answer is they could use
either front or rear if they were the
delivery driver Thank You Chancellor
Perry I'm also waiting because just to
start to keep things going
I do have great concern about this
actually it's rare that the you know the
parish cancer and the Wold member and
there's the there are objections to it I
think the crux of the whole thing is you
know they've already got a significant
amount of takeaways I think
I can understand from the carrot parish
councils perspective they're trying to
keep the character of studly village
going and unchanging it to yet another
take away irrespective but it's a it's
an ash big national chain coming in it
does give me concern in terms of the
character of the village because
inevitably it will have it will have an
impact having a yet another take away
particularly as as the ward member
identified there are already provisions
from takeaways in the village providing
pizza a pizza service so my my reasons
would be for going on the on the refusal
side would be the impact of the
character off of on the street scene and
also the vibrancy of Studley because I
think if you've got this type of
operation coming in it kind of changes
the sort of the whole nighttime scene
etc because we're talking 11 a.m. to 11
p.m. so I've got big concerns about this
so I must I think we've got to come up
with some very strong planning reasons
to bump it up I do think the impact on
the character of the landscape is is a
significant one in order to protect the
heritage and future proofs Dudley as a
vibrant village thank you
cancer feeling in that there are two or
three empty take fast-food restaurants
again are quite the reason whether it's
to do with the lack of parking in the
area because to parking the coop carpark
and cross the road which is a very
dangerous road at the best of times and
you've got parking around
back I think that in my opinion it ought
to be refused on the grounds that there
isn't a adequate parking be there are I
know one can't say it's too many in the
area because when it's taking a planning
application on the site we're looking at
but I think these have got to be
considered Thank You counselor anyone
else wants contribute no I am gonna need
to look for a proposal now the feeling
I'm getting from those that have spoken
is that you are erring on the side of
refusing but you're seeking for reasons
to refuse what I've heard so far
inadequate parking from councilor
fielding Street scene and vitality and
vibrancy of of the town center
sensibly now our last reason for refusal
and I can read the full thing to you if
you want but on last reason refusal was
as it was against policies here 22 in
terms of economic development that we're
seeking to promote a more vibrant
steadily main sadly center and that the
change of use away from financial
services into another take away would go
against that would you let me to read
the full reason for refusal or you happy
in your minds that we're looking at the
same sort of thing I'm happy to go along
with what you're suggesting and would
propose that we refuse so refused on the
grounds of the same as last unto a
vibrancy of vitality and the multitude
of shops that study want to see and also
the inner inadequacy of parking
available for the property
so we have one proposal on that I also
think chaired that there is an impact on
the character of the street scene and
that's that that's a clear that is a
material planning reason that's Rea the
character yeah impact on the landscape
and character the character of the of
the street scene okay I'm gonna just
very quickly so is that is that a second
to cancel feelings proposal or are you
just wanting to explore that as one of
our reasons I'm quite I thought actually
that council herb answered propose but
maybe not disagree with the reason that
the chairman has put forward and they do
feel the reason that you put forward
it's like any other shop so I don't
think we would okay so just so we're
clear I was putting I was giving you the
reminder of our previous reason for
refusal on the basis of what I'd heard
certainly I've got the feeling back from
members that you're prepared to move
forward with that I'm going to look at
my officers or our officers and say how
so the reasons you've heard are you
comfortable that those are sufficient
and adequate reason is to refuse I'm not
I'm afraid and the key reason I say that
is because a year ago members refused it
chiefly on the vitality of Studley two
things have changed since then that
could change that and both of them
suggest now that this should be granted
the first thing that's changes we have
an inspectors decision considering
exactly the same issue and that
inspector took into account he held a
view that there were actually 16 hot
food takeaways in Studley however the
work done by our policy team to produce
SPD reveals that there are 14 nine of
which are pure hot food takeaways and
five of which are restaurants with an
element of take away so my advice to you
is
that that inspectors decision is a key
material consideration and I would ask
you to take that into account the other
point I would make on the additional
reasons refusal a year ago committee
refused it on that single ground that
the chairman has read out I'm not aware
of any material changes that would now
justify additional reasons refusal for
what is essentially the same scheme and
additionally seeks to make visual
improvements to the site so I'm
struggling to see how you would sustain
a reason now objecting on visual grounds
when the applicant is sought to improve
the visual outlook of the site and on
parking grounds again we didn't use it
last time I understand that but is that
something we get out if it needs to be
here yes might may address that mostly
both on this application on the previous
refusal there was no technical
objections from the high-waist county
college team and as Richard touched upon
there's been no material changes from
that person to this I would say in the
highways parking arrangements from last
time okay counselor feeling when the
appeal was exam was granted were there
the same number of empty facilities for
fast-food restaurants at the time if I
just read from what the inspector viewed
inspector used evidence that was
provided by the applicant on that case
and they said that there were 62 shops
cos a 111 financial and professional
that's Class A two and 16 hot food
takeaways that's a five and that
inspector considered that that level was
acceptable in terms of its impact on
Studley obviously you've heard that
there's evidence now that it's actually
less than that in any event which
suggests that the inspector was using
that higher figure than he needed to so
called strategy not carry any weight or
the proposed course traffic absolutely
yeah the core strategy carries carries
full weight and policy cs4 sorry
neighbourhood plan my apologies the
neighbourhood planned well the neighbour
plan has only just been made there's a
parish plan and again that would that
looks at the balance of services within
sadly shops and services and the
vitality and effectively it covers the
same issue that the inspector had to
cover when they made their decision
Castle Perry chairman on on the basis of
what the Planning Manager has come
forward with whilst I'm not happy with
it I don't think the planning reasons
that I've given first forward will be
strong enough and we do have to bear in
mind cost implications to this council
so with regret I think I'm going to
withdraw from my proposal for if we're
not proposing thoughts on a refusal
because I just sadly I just don't think
that my recommendations would be strong
enough to stand up okay thank you very
much Chancellor Bantz like I said really
to start with there were more takeaways
before than there is now
I didn't really see a reason the solid
reason proposal so to move it forward I
will propose what the officers are
recommending because they are
recommending it twice if you want to put
it that way
to move it forward okay thank you we
have a proposal looking for a seconder
proposal to grant yeah thank you okay
that's been seconded now we did have a
proposal to refuse which was from
councillor fielding he did have a second
ever that has been withdrawn so
councillor fielding for councillors
fielding excuse me for councillor
Fielding's proposed to refuse father is
there anyone to support that as their
seconder for that on the reasons that
were given earlier
you can't second yourself on the freight
okay in that case and in that case that
refusal sorry that proposal to refuse
has fallen we will move then to the
proposal to grant in line with the
offers recommendation and anything in
the update sheet could I have a show of
hands please
and anyone against thank you and
abstentions
okay in that case the committee have
determined to grant application 1802 to
76 ful in line with the officers
recommendation
thank you very much members so while we
have a very quick change of case officer
I was just next item so we will now be
looking at application 1803 7 1 0 ful
the old post office cottage in sambal
our case officer presenting will be
Eddie wrench he is just finding his
paperwork and as soon as he has he is
free to dive straight in
[Music]
Thank You chair the application before
you is a garden studio the application
site is located at the southern end of
Sanborn opposite the village green as
ternate adhere by the black dot this is
the proposed site plan with a garden
studio located at the southern end of
the side garden to the mayor hosts
property this plan shows the proposed
elevations and floor plans for the
studio this photo shows the front of the
dwelling including the side garden and
shows the approximate location of the
studio this photo is from within the
side garden towards the proposed siting
of the studio this is a slightly closer
view of the proposed location as part of
the application very special
circumstances put forward by the
application state that the alternative
locations for the garden studio to
either within five metres of the side
elevation within the rear garden space
would have detrimental impacts on
neighbors and/or to the character of the
area however it is of the offices
consideration that both of these
alternatives would require planning
permission and are therefore no more
than a theoretical possibilities
possibility which cannot be considered
fallback positions furthermore in
planning terms both of these alternative
locations are considered to be more
harmful from more harmful than that
proposed Chairman updates include a
supporting statement from the ward
member which is in the update sheet
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
planning permission for the reason
detailed on page 24 of the agenda thank
you thank you very much straight to our
first speakers parish council so it's
counselor Flip bonds welcome I'm sure
you've done this before but I think
you've got a gist three minutes if you
press the middle button red light on the
show and I'll give you a 30-second
warning if you could stay seated
afterwards for questions thank you
whenever you ready
yes sir
yes thank you for the opportunity very
much to speak before the committee I
address you today as a member of Sanborn
Parish Council a resident and someone
who was actually born in the parish I
therefore feel that I'm well-placed to
know the feeling on the ground all
members of Sanborn Parish Council
unanimously support this application the
neighbors support and there are no
objections the applicant has cited
special circumstances and the parish
council find this case convincing the
applicant has resided in Sanborn for
over 20 years during which time he has
sympathetically restored the external
appearance of the old post office and
has always been mindful of its location
in the center of the village this is
evident by the planned location of the
intended studio being 20 metres away
rather than opting for it nearer to the
house however the first consideration
has always been where best to locate the
studio for appearance purposes citing
the studio at the end of the side garage
garden reduces its visual impact thus
allowing the old post office to remain
as a dominant feature within the street
scene this would be very different if
the studio is located within 5 meters to
the left of the dwelling that would then
clearly be visible from the village
green neighbors at Green Grove green run
cottage has cited four good reasons for
their support of the application they
believe the studio is visually
attractive and would fit well into the
area being close to their detached
cottage surrounded by trees it will
aesthetically enhanced the proposed site
of installation rather than detract
moreso due to the density of the foilage
separating the two properties the studio
would be virtually invisible unlike if
it were located within five meters to
the right of the old post office
following a site visit I agree with the
applicant and the views cited within the
special
this document the location is not
detrimental to the village nor in our
opinion harmful to the Greenbelt nor
neighbors amenities are not compromised
it is the opinion of the parish council
therefore that the location chosen by
the applicant is the most suitable
nestled in by the next-door neighbor's
detached garage the scale and design of
the proposed studio is in keeping with
the location 30 seconds
it does seem disproportionate to
discriminate against this application
simply due to the garden falling within
the curtilage of the conservation area
to conclude therefore we propose the
intended location is the most suitable
site has no harmful detrimental impact
on the village and has the full and
unanimous support of the parish council
also we have the full support of our
ward member so I ask for leniency and
flexibility in its application and I
thank you for your time thank you very
much probably officers done yeah I've
just been told if I happens use too many
meters but the it's it's it's a fair
distance and it's the location is it's
the best location in terms of the actual
real estate scene and the village any
other members for a question no okay
thank you very much so we're moving that
case to our next speaker which is the
applicant mr. Peter now I'm definitely
gonna get this wrong is it tough oh I'm
on fire so again you have three minutes
I'll give you a 30-second warning and
whenever you're ready please to go
thank you first of all my thanks
destructor district council for allowing
me to reapply for my upon application
based on what I believe to be special
circumstances the reason why my initial
application was refused was due to cs10
and greenbelt not erecting the garden
studio within 5 meters of the dwelling I
understand if I was able to erect the
studio within 5 meters then the
application would have likely been
granted however there are a number of
reasons why this in my mind is not
practical if I located the studio within
5 meters are dwelling to the left side
of the dwelling as shown on page one of
my special circumstances document and
that could be clearly seen from the
village green and I'm sure sambal and
parish counts who would object on that
basis not forgetting and I think this is
important that 7/10 water supply reading
green dragon cottage is actually
directly in that area along with their
main sewers that kind of runs across my
land to the outer perimeter of the at my
side garden if we then look at the right
side of the dwelling within five meters
unshown on page 2 of my special
circumstances document this location
would be clearly viewed from my
neighbor's a green dragon cottage and in
their full view from their only garden
area they don't have a rear garden as it
happens and located directly over their
main sewer which again runs across my
land based on the above the only like
only likely location are shown on page 4
in my special circus document is the
rear of our side garden nestled
alongside green dragon cottages detached
garage separated by a 1.8 litre fencing
and surrounding trees and shrubs
I recognize that my preferred location
is greater than 5 metres some 15 metres
more but this location in my opinion is
not harmful or detrimental to the
Greenbelt area the main material uses
construction in stained wood finish grey
painted doors and windows which I
believe sits in well in this location
and is manufactured to a very high state
moving on to Stratford district councils
recommendation of locating in our small
well-developed two rear garden again I
looked at various locations are shown on
page two and three of my special
circumstances document firstly to the
left side of the dwelling next to what
is green dragon cottages rear ground
floor WC location here would have an
effect on our neighbors rights to
maintain the rear of the property
including possible erection of
scaffolding should they wish to maintain
their roof 30 seconds thank you
it would also reduce the amount of light
into their WC I also believe from
information provided from a local
builder that that area also has a well
situated below ground before to locate
the studio along the right side of the
rear guard and adjacent to our neighbors
at big stand detached carrots and I know
their neighbors at biston would object
on the grounds it would clearly be seen
an upper school their outlook across
fields and it's important to know that
our rear garden is elevated above their
garden machine stop working I'm throwing
out to stop you actually just run over
okay I'm gonna open up for questions for
our councillors council Barnes first of
all similar question looking at the map
you were saying that if it was within
five meters of the house it would have
an effect on the green that's why you
got it where you yes
I prefer that location because he's add
to the way took two at the bottom the
garden and can't be seen from the green
yeah oh good okay any other cancer
Parkinson's
okay the dimension is roughly 3.8 by
five meters it's got internal dimension
of three and a half meters by four I
think from memory and the reason for it
really is that I've just recently
retired and it will give me an
opportunity to spend some time away from
the main house and to do whatever I want
to and I don't mean that in fact in any
way shape or form at the front of the
house our house looks really quite large
but the house is very long and narrow
and we only have a lounge and a small
study so they just follow up we used
entirely for recreation yeah no business
activity normal okay thanks a lot okay
thank you unless there are any other
questions from monomers which I don't
think they're armed thank you very much
appreciate your contribution now we
don't have a war member although she has
written a letter of support which you'll
find in your update sheet so I'm sure
you've all had a chance to read that
already so we will move in that case two
questions to the officers there was a
question about the distance away which
I'm sure you guys can give us very
quickly yeah I think it was overheard is
actually going to be 20 yeah well the
current position is 20 meters from the
main dwelling okay cancel bonds was that
question you're going to ask okay any
other questions boxes yeah so got George
you got you go first cuz you you had the
visibility of the location where it will
be prominent fall I mean could want if
there's a member of the public where
would you pass and say oh look at that
garden shed or would it be entirely
hidden I mean is they gonna give us any
advice on that
these well potentially it's going to be
located close to white claim yeah white
line which is this one so here is the
lane so it's going to be position here
so potentially you know there's a
hedgerow at them currently so you might
see wheezing from there should sort of
see a bit more from there roughly so
that's from that Lane councillor Barnes
he had a question sort of in the respect
the reasonable refusal is it's a
building in the Greenbelt if we were to
approve it what is the conditions I mean
to me I didn't know they hadn't gone
through the materials or anything
we I think we don't those are standard
but we'll get to that as we go through
the debate I think the to understand
let's let's not try and preempt any
decision as you know you might make
cancer Paris yes can I just ask the
offices because obviously in the report
it whilst this has come forward trying
to identify special circumstances and
what you're saying is that special
circumstances are removed because it's a
theoretical a proposition that you could
have the building five metres away but
we can't we can't use that what I would
just like to ask is is in terms of
obviously with with the Greenbelt the
special circumstances are just totally
paramount for any building in the
Greenbelt and I just just a
clarification on precedent if we were to
go to
against it okay the building as proposed
is inappropriate development in the
Greenbelt as many certain buildings are
this is one of them therefore the only
way to outweigh that harm easy to find
very special circumstances and you've
heard from the applicants we've heard
from the parish and you'll read the
officers report a possible very special
circumstance can be a fallback position
and the applicant has described two
possible fall backs one being if they
were to construct it to the side of the
house was to the southeast of it there
and he has made the case that that would
be more prominent from the village green
so you'll have to take that into account
as to whether that actually weighs in
favor of granting it where its proposed
similarly he's made the case that in the
rare garden there's a fall back there
the fall but being that if you don't
grant this if this is refused he could
build it there and it would cause harm
to his neighbors that kind of thing and
again that's a thought that could be a
fallback position and just to conclude
then a fallback position can be a very
special circumstance that outweighs the
harm by reason of inappropriateness
sorry I just add one thing and when
we're talking about five metres as well
by positioning it within five metres of
the house it's classified as an
extension so it's not necessarily that
we're saying that it has to be within
five metres of the house just for it to
be not in appropriate development if it
was located within that he wouldn't need
very special circumstances to be shown
so that's the only difference and
similarly to the rear garden there's the
potential that he could erect that under
permitted development so it's not quite
it depends on the amount of works and
where we just situate it but the
potential is there that you could do it
in the permitted development which is
slightly different as well so it's it's
not quite as critical thank you just
just to help sorry chairman just out
it's a bit it's an unknown because we
haven't have plans put forward for the
alternatives which is why it may be
coming across as a little bit
wishy-washy but what
saying is it's within your gift is
decision-maker to use a fallback
position as a very special circumstance
cancel answer are we saying that the
fallback position would not need to come
to committee what I'm trying to
ascertain I mean if we were to defer it
if there's a fallback position
do you understand what I'm saying it's
fallback position it's over five meters
but it is suitable possible for the
fallback to carry weight you only need
to set it be satisfied that it's more
than theoretically possible okay no
further questions of clarity good let's
move to the debate who would like to
start counselor organ Thank You chairman
I see no reason to to change from the
position that the committee had last
time this came here the Greenbelt is a
very special protected area and I do not
see any very special circumstances that
would make me consider that this was
therefore appropriate development so I
support the officers recommendation
thank you is that a proposal or is that
just a support proposal Thank You
councillor Perry
Thank You chair having heard the offices
explanation I'm I'm in line with
councillor Alban and I'm happy to second
her proposal
I don't feel the special circumstances
are significant enough
I think there's opportunities for the
applicant perhaps to go back and have
further discussions with the planning
team to see if they can find find a more
appropriate place or scaled-down type of
extension that would give give the
applicant the space that he's looking
for
so I will second this proposal Greenbelt
is sacrosanct and we have to do
everything we can to protect it to avoid
a precedent being set I agree
Cattleman's okay unless there are any
other speakers we have we have a
seconder we will move to the vote so can
I have a show of hands then please to
refuse in line with the offers
recommendation in the report and against
that proposal and abstentions okay thank
you in that case committee resolves to
refuse planning permission 1803 7 1 0
ful inline with the opposition report
Thank You councillor caret is making his
way back do you want a minute or shall I
just carry on in the chair cause we're
on a roll
you Conan we just switch over them okay
we're gonna have two minutes off one
minute so how long it's going to take
good thank you very much can we go to
our next number please thank you thank
you chair the application is for a
single story front rear and side
extensions the application site is
located off blind lane to the west of
town within Arden as shown here in the
center this is the proposed site plan
with the existing dwelling a shaded in
gray and the proposed extensions
outlined to the rear side and at the
front and above the existing hip roof as
shown here on the left this blue that
this plan shows the existing front and
rear elevations on the left and the
proposed elevations on the right hand
side similarly this shows the existing
you proposed side elevations of the
property here are the existing two
proposed floor plans with the existing
dwelling have two having two ground
floor bedrooms on one first floor and
the proposed having an additional
bedroom on the first floor this slide
shows the existing extensions to the
property and the proposed alterations on
the right this is a street view of the
application dwelling in the center again
this is a close-up of the front of the
property as it exists this is the garage
located down the side of the dwelling
here is the rear elevation of the
property this is the rear viewer veer
view of the property but looking towards
the neighbor neighboring property and
finally this is a view of the existing
side rear elevation up two updates
include a supporting document from the
applicant chairman the recommendation is
to refuse permission for the reasons
detailed on pages 32 and
three of the agenda thank you thank you
very much and moving on to our speakers
Paul TIPNIS the applicant who has three
minutes good evening
just press the little button in the
middle red light should come on you
start when you're ready and we'll we'll
take you three minutes from when you
begin you want to just give me a nod or
something when you want me to change or
yeah
can you remember to press the button
little bit disappointed to be here from
honest we've spent many months analyzing
our schemes to get to strike the balance
between children and mainland sea for
our family of five son and twin
daughters who are growing and keeping
the respects of our neighbors so we've
gone for a low profile we're extension
and minor modifications to the front of
the roof which think has been sold as
for an extension but actually it's
changing the hip to a gable end
having said that reading the committee
report I'm pleased to see that our hard
work has bed some through the fact that
we've got some support on arguably five
or six of the core policy documents with
the exception of three objections one
one is parking which can clearly be seen
from the photo on the presentation there
there is adequate space for at least six
vehicles despite the case of saying two
and the second two arguments effectively
entwined and that's on the basis of
scale which has been in the words of the
case obviously and based on a defunct
30-percent brawl which now no no longer
sits in
the policy if a person to the slides
employees
here's a image from Google Maps
it shows the rebuild line of the
neighboring properties the increase of
the utilization on the site from our
prop from our proposals is only 7% and
the rear boundaries line sits 37 meters
behind the proposed extension
Bottenfield is just center of the plan
there it shows the mass and scale the
analysis of the night bring 13 dwellings
both left and right on opposite suggests
that they're in the region of 444 meters
cubed whereas our proposed at least 336
and I just like to say that to put it
into context of the street this is an
urban street this is not a quiet area
right next to the dual carriageway and
therefore we'd argue is negligible
impact on the Greenbelt
particularly when referring to the 30
seconds document which got a checklist
in there that says talking about schemes
being sympathetic if I can roll through
the slides quickly on the photographs
the front hips guy will change mirrors
the neighboring properties directly
opposite us in the scale next slide
please
photo from the rear show in low lines
which is approximately 5.5 meters
further down the garden than ours that's
the neighboring property to the right
and you can see the size and mass of the
buildings to the left very dense it
okay thank you for that however any
questions councillor bombs
we have amended the parish council I see
that made any comments we've consulted
with our neighbors we try to consider
the planners as the result of ever since
a dyke we've had zero objections from
anybody that includes ecology parish our
neighbours okay can't serve Richards
thank you for that from your google map
image obvious we're looking top down the
property to the left of your house when
you're looking at the front door yeah
yes the one with that one forward that's
it yep so to the left of your where your
house is marked that to me looks quite a
significant property it also looks
fairly modern can you tell me how
recently that was changed if indeed it
was changed my research tells me
nineteen ITC was when it was past
nineteen eighty when it was built dive
shop cancer Perry thank you good evening
I just wondered when in when you were
looking at putting your thoughts and
ideas together did you look at the
extensions
extending your home policy for Stratford
district council with the documents 2000
eight and carefully look at the you know
all the sides in terms of being
subservient to the main dwelling and
that sort of thing we've looked at that
with two reference from the excuse me
from the policy check list as well
there's only references proportions
ethic which we believe it is it's your
interpretation of it that's great thank
you any other questions no thank you
very much
it sounds great and we shall now hear
from cancer Atkins in the ward member
who has five minutes and before I begin
can I have up the street scene which the
officer showed I think there's a
different one to this which had more of
the properties adjacent to the dwelling
with white shots
okay and then secondly if I may on page
32 there is the comment there would be
insufficient off street parking to serve
that extent are you starting no no I
write the statement and we're in the
start your five minutes writers I think
on page 32 the statement there would be
insufficient off-street pardon to serve
that extended dwelling is incorrect the
parking capacity could be at least six
cars is I would ask the officer to
confirm that later on I think what is
necessary here chairman is to compare
this application with a number of others
which have gone through some without
appeal others with appeal and I was
looking at one in a area by the name of
Clevedon actually which was a delegated
refusal it didn't come to a committee
because of the exact circumstances for
refusal which are being expressed this
evening the report and here I quote from
it actually previous extensions to the
cottage has been oblique would be
significantly extended resulting in harm
to the Greenbelt now no quantifiable
measurement is
the only volume opinion is that previous
extensions extensions added volume by
more than doubling the width of the
property the width of the property
nevermind the other dimension so that
would probably in my estimation be well
into about 200% the volume increase here
is in my opinion pretty well related to
the site which is there the proposed
development in my belief would not
constitute inappropriate development for
the purpose of either national or
development plant policy therefore there
is no conflict with policy cs10 that
actually when I say I believe is the
expression used by the inspector when he
allowed via appeal for the development
of the property in travellin policy cs10
which has been invoked here as a reason
to refuse actually the nature of the
development in the Greenbelt and
particularly relating to an application
of this type was well explained by a
Nina Pinta m-- of number five chambers
who actually gave us a training course
here now she did quote from a law case
and here I'll read it to you if new
building is a partial redevelopment of a
previously developed site it is not to
be regarded as inappropriate
redevelopment in the Greenbelt provided
that it has no greater impact on the
openness of the brain Belt than the
existing development I think that is a
very important factor as far as this
application is concerned and similar
application was refused but a committee
with similar issues about Greenbelt that
again was successful at appeal it again
was in Clevedon and costs were awarded
against
the council for that now I give you the
interpretation of an inspection
inspectors report as well as Nina
pendants in talking to us about
development on them in the green belt
about policy cs10 which this application
claims to impinge upon to me the
extension at the rear has no conflict
with the five principles about
development restrictions in the green
belt
you haven't got communities coming
together you haven't got a structure in
this instance which is larger than the
roof height of the existing dwelling no
increase in height will be seen apart
from a slight modification at the front
and it is a modification of the front it
is not a redevelopment in summary I
believe and certainly the two inspectors
opinions I've mentioned to you talking
about policy cs10 so I get a lot of
confidence from that to me there is no
adverse impact upon the openness of the
Greenbelt the development is at the back
it will not be seen from the front of
all indeed the area no adverse impact is
on the setting no adverse impact is upon
neighbors no adverse impact is upon the
streets in all issues I have seen in
other appeals which have been successful
which inspectors have invoked to allow
the application against the refusal I
hope members accept that reasoning and I
certainly commend the application to you
the traffic tymek thank you cancer and
I'll take up your point about parking I
think it's well made by both you in the
applicant with the officers later are
there any questions
castor bombs damn G green in your pants
yes it is actually wasn't appeal went to
the next engineer a bit back yeah
I'm not I don't think so there was a a
remodeling of an application for a site
by the name of Robin Hood form that went
through and is still an ongoing
situation but there is nothing as far as
I know identical to this although I
assure your counselor bonds similar
extensions in the Greenbelt have been
granted not just as appeal but at this
committee any other questions
when can I finish Chairman which gives
an idea okay in particular when we had
this 30 percent restriction the dynamic
committee actually supported an
extension where the volume increase was
okay so we're going to can you turn the
thing off please George the bottle right
yeah thank you questions to the offices
council organ Thank You chairman I am
confused about this extension to the
front of the property can I have it
explain to me please to the very front
of the property basically what they're
proposing is to change it from a hipped
roof to a gable so basically pull the
ridge hike across here today it's a
higher front put it on the site
[Music]
there was a picture so yeah you can see
that the existing so the existing is
hipped and they want to bring it out and
there's a slight bit of an extension
there as well yes clarification the bay
windows at the front will go it will be
a fat platform that will project further
point six of a meter in front of the
existing building yes there's a slight
extension in this part and then it comes
up from the existing eaves straight up
to the ridge line at the main house so
it's purely that bit there that extends
forward this bit here would actually be
forward that would be forward from the
roof if that makes sense
okay thank you I understand point six
four meter okay Calipari thank you Thank
You chair my query relates to a
technical issue really obviously in the
offices report it talks about the
extensions being much you know too large
there's too many different extensions I
would just welcome some some comment on
the fact that if the applicant had come
resubmitted this as a replacement
dwelling would that have overcome the
extensions policy because I had a very
similar application in my ward where
where we were concerned with the over
extension sending front side and rear
and the applicant withdrew put it
through as a replacement and it was the
same plans and it has got permission and
I would just from a technicality point
of view nothing has changed with the
nothing has changed of design the
difference perhaps
is that this other application wasn't in
the green belt but it was it reflected
the same comments in the officers report
about the extensions having to be
subservient to the main host Wehling and
because they weren't it was getting
turned down on that because of scale and
size so in that case the applicant
resubmitted as a replacement dwelling
and it's gone straight through so it we
just I've just be interested to hear the
officers views on explanation to the
policy one of the to take into account
is the tests is that where it's the
replacement of a building it's
acceptable provided that the new
building is in the same use and not
materially larger than the one it
replaces so that that's the test for a
placement dwelling tests were talking
about on this is whether it's
disproportionate so the test is similar
but not identical but I would say
they're similar so if this came back for
a replacement dwelling that would be the
test to apply obviously I can't say
which way we go on it but there is a
test there that I view is similar to the
one that's before us tonight okay
counsel about the extent here at the
front and next door the street scene are
we looking at this new property being
similar to next law there was a picture
that looked I think it was from the
front somehow and you and looking at the
thing we've got the bit in the roof what
I was trying to ask the same was will
that this will not dominate what he's
next door you understand was he going to
be similar what in character terms well
yeah I mean I know what the height will
be the same as it currently is obviously
they're just extensions to the front so
it's going to be visually different
within the
street scene but it's not going to be
larger than the neighboring property no
okay and I have one whoa - and she went
on parking that does seem to be room for
two cars not not on the schematic
weren't even on the schematic driver but
on the photograph with any comments on
that really or should we just make our
own judgment on that as you can see on
the drawing in front of you it's not
been demonstrated that more than two
cars was looking at that picture to make
that and the other thing is on the exact
wording of cs10 the Greenbelt policy
we've talked about the new build in the
report we're talking about comparing
things to original build size so can you
maybe read out the bit in the green bell
policy which talks about that same part
of cs10 and it will be acceptable in the
green melt is the extension or
alteration of a building provided that
it does not result in disproportionate
additions over and above the size of the
original building it's not set out in
policy but for the purposes of
consistency officers take the original
building to be what was there in 1975
when the green boat was designated or
what was their original when it was
built if it was built later than 1975
okay thank you
no more questions so there's any water
stylus for debate councillor Richards
Thank You chairman let me address the
parking thing first whilst on that
drawing only shows two cars is so
abundantly clear that those two cars are
part-time placidly in a in a pencil
drawing when we look at it you know you
could get at least two more cars
not sure I could accept six but
certainly for possibly a fit so I'm
perhaps that you rule that out so for me
this balls down to the Greenbelt issue
council Atkinson very eloquently talks
about the two bills in collaborative I
happen to know of it that's pop my ward
so I'm aware of those I happen to know a
couple in this field as well that I've
gone in the same way where this council
have either refused or the committee of
refused to greenbelt extension on the
basis that we are doing now my
experience has always been that a as
appeal the appeal inspector considers
the the original dwelling size to be the
size it is when it's looking to be
extended so my view is that this is not
inappropriate development in the
Greenbelt because I do not believe that
this extension is disproportionate in
terms of its current size the size of
the current building the original
building not withstanding that when we
look at the rest of the street scene the
size of the dwellings surrounding this
property are significant I would suggest
that this is probably the only one that
hasn't been extended to any great form
particularly if we're looking at the one
I referred to earlier the one on the
left of the property which is huge
I find it insane that we would even
consider refusing what I understand
Greenbelt the policy is sacrosanct and
we have to protect the Greenbelt in this
instance there is no material impact on
the openness of the Greenbelt by virtue
of the size of the dwellings that is
that are surrounding the existing and
also the in my view not disproportionate
to size of extension so actually I
propose that we do grant permission for
this extension for this for this
application with standards conditions as
we would normally would council organ
Thank You chairman I agree with counsel
Richards and will second we did suppose
yes and would second that it is
Greenbelt yes a Greenbelt is very
special but you also have to be
reasonable about
what is special and what is special and
what is Greenbelt what is actually an
urban street scene within the Greenbelt
so what is reasonable in terms of
extending a property within that urban
street scene that sits within the
Greenbelt would the extensions that are
proposed be disproportionate to what is
with the neighbors and the general
street scene would it be something that
would stick out like a sore thumb with
any views from the Greenbelt and I can't
answer yes to any of those I can't see
what harm this would cause so that's my
reason for supporting okay thank you
secondly we're going to go to canister
bans in a moment we've had a proposed in
a second I just like you guys to clarify
between yourselves perhaps if you're
going for it not being inappropriate or
being inappropriate and there being
special circumstances because that is
deemed by office I was very clear about
that you were there
there's not an increase that therefore
is not okay thank you
cancer bombs thank you situation is that
this was an open countryside this size
and book increase although it's at the
back would I think have an effect on the
Greenbelt but in this particular
position row houses at the back not at
the front the street scene virtually
doesn't change that's why I asked the
question about the height of next door
so I'm fully supportive with the last
two speakers because like the one that I
was still wouldn't we lady came and
talked about took the building in the
Greenbelt and she used her want a dam G
green where it was quite a bit bigger
but the material was were right
the design was right and it went to on
appeal so
I'm pretty supportive of granting this
I'm fully supportive if you look at the
Google map where the red line was along
the back it doesn't extend beyond to any
extent beyond the neighboring houses and
I can see no reason why it should be
refused and I go along with councillor
Richards and cancer or cancer parent
chairman I get a sound a bit like a tape
recorder because it is I agree with my
colleagues I think it's actually the
proposed application will enhance the
street scene because it at the moment
it's the odd one out because it's it is
so small so I think it would be
complementary I'm surprised I've got to
say this about face later on the
committee
compared to Greenbelt considerations
early on ok this is a very difficult
application the the the report officers
clearly state that they consider this to
be inappropriate they clearly state that
they as a point of principle always take
the 1975 volume as the original volume
original volume is what's mentioned in
our policy and if it's national policy
but our policy which Trump's national
policy anyway
I'm in favor of this application but I
do believe it is in principle
inappropriate and but because of its
situation because of the improvement in
design and and the street scene being so
urban I would I would put forward a
selection of very special circumstances
I cannot vote for this proposal which is
going against offices in saying that it
is not inappropriate but we shall take
we should take this vote as it comes I
think now we've all said something
I'm going to allow the officer to make a
comment yeah just just who's on my side
just to clarify the the first point
about the original building you'll be
pleased to hear that our local policy
complies with national policy on that so
that the to dovetail just in terms of if
members are seeking to grant permission
there's two ways that they could do that
you could as councillor Richards has
said decide that it's not
disproportionate in the first place that
would mean that it is not in appropriate
development if you still consider it is
a disproportionate you wouldn't then
need to find very special circumstances
the other points the parking and the
design have been adequately covered I
can understand the reasons why members
might seek to overrule the office
recommendation I do not believe it is
disproportionate and therefore was okay
okay we'll go to the vote all those in
favor of granting this application on
these reasons yeah okay yeah so we're
going to grant this so the reasons
clearly clearly given by by councilor
Richards we're going to talk about
conditions now the suggested conditions
members for you to consider would be the
standard three-year condition for
commencement and approved plans
condition and I would suggest the
removal of permitted development rights
for extensions on this property and
possibly outbuildings but I'll leave
that to you
materials could be done through the
approved plans because they show what
it's to be constructed of I'm happy with
it I'm also happy with the PD thing it
was on my mind so I'm sure okay so for
extensions and outbuildings okay so we
have resolved grant to a grant
permission for planning application in
1803 106 full with the conditions just
discussed and we ready for our next
application yep great yes we normally do
so Stuart thank you very much Thank You
chairman this is a full application for
the erection of a temporary seasonal
dome cover to court numbers three and
four of Strafford sports club
misapplications been brought to
committee by virtue of the district
council having a land holding on the
abacus application sites meaning it
can't be decided by delegated powers
this application site is within the town
centre of Stratford as illustrated by
the black dots on this plan this is an
aerial satellite view of the application
sites you can fry it again by the the
arrow one can see the application site
here and listen to its relation both to
the town centre one can see the River
Avon here the tramway footpath which
runs alongside the application sites
here the ships and Road running along
down here and other features one can
also see also see the tennis courts in
their current form with the wider
Leisure recreational language so that
surrounds it this is the submitted site
location plan which shows the
applications sites in detail in the red
with the red line and listen to the blue
line signifying the applicants land
ownership in addition here we see the
submitted site layout plan with the
proposed East elevation as viewed from
the tramway footpath located beneath on
this visual we can see the two separate
temporary domes that were approved or a
different application in 2013 next to
the proposed dome here the subject of
this application here we see the
proposed Western North elevations of the
dome the dome when erected is posted
comprised of a translucent translucent
polythene membrane and is eight meters
higher its highest point in the centre
here from ground level here we can see
an indicative height of the dome in
relation to the tramway
here which is elevated with existing
mature trees and vegetation
found it here we can see some images
that provided by the applicants within
the designer statement showing the type
of dome that is before you this evening
here we also see some images of the
associate equipment associated with it
so one can see the fans here there is a
revolving door and a typical storage
show that's also being proposed within
this application here we had now stood
on the actual tentacle itself on the
northwestern corner of court number
three looking eastwards we can see the
two flood lighting columns or partly
anyway one here and one tennis flooding
column there which are proposed to be
moved to the perimeter as part of this
proposal as well
here we've stood in the same position
now looking southwards here we have
stood now in the center of the two
courts looking westwards towards the
raised area of the tramway here try my
footpath one can also see the existing
with your trees or vegetation which are
seen here in full leaf here we're now
stood on the pedestrian footpath by the
recreational grounds on the southwestern
corner of application of sites one can
see the well-maintained
hedgerow mature hedgerow that's
screening the tennis courts from view
with exception of the tops of the flood
lighting columns as they currently are
here we're now stood on the pedestrian
tramway itself and an elevated position
looking down on the two courts that
subject this application looking
eastwards and here finally we're sitting
now on the pedestrian footpath again on
the recreation ground looking southeast
woods here we can actually see the to
approve domes erected and to give you an
idea of what they would look like
essentially these are the two approved
domes on quartz five and six the
application site is here for court
numbers three and four that concludes my
presentation chairman there are no
updates to report chairman the
recommendations to grant the application
for the reason sets out on pages 45 and
46 of your agendas thank you thank you
we have no speakers on this are there
any questions to the officers Council
organ thank you
I note that the application includes
floodlight alterations and I would like
to know if in the officers opinion the
amended floodlights would have any
detrimental impact on the residential
properties along gypsum Road that would
be different to the existing flood that
caused by the existing flood lights of
course yes I'm clearly matters of
fertilizing an amenity or our report and
consideration to clarify perhaps this
plan will show there we saw on the photo
there are two flood lots of columns
there and there hopefully things see if
it's not the best plan open you can see
essentially one misting moods that
location there the other one thing look
at moved to that location there on the
perimeter I have certainly considered
the impacts of the foot lighting
positioning being changed and indeed the
applicants who provided flood lighting
specifications within an application
submission having consulted those plan
those documents and I believe I've
touched on in a neighboring amenity
section of my report I'm satisfied that
there is no detrimental impacts on
amenity by virtue of that slight
alteration and I think there's some
technical stuff as well relating to the
exact I'm not going to the technical
lingo but essentially it's proposed to
be actually a lessened impact is what
it's two geared to be essentially so I
could go into more detail if you wish
but since we've hit some very loud
yeah council Richard thanks um so this
I've got no particular issue with this
but the recommendation includes wording
and detail of hours of operation but it
doesn't say anything about reason for
operation we obviously know it's a
seasonal the picture we saw there showed
a clear blue sky but were the domes up I
can only assume that that's because it
was getting a little bit dark and they
wants to play with it later and tonight
presumably this is purely for winter
months and rain so I'd like to see
something in there about that if that's
something we
but potentially I mean one condition
that I've suggested in the
recommendation session is potential
hours of operation per se within but
that's been more than the rumor of a day
I don't know if there's something that
we can put in place for certain times of
the year or not that's not something
that's in place for the current domes
they're up currently it's to me it just
seems a bit perverse that you would burn
up a seasonal seasonal dope
that can be used in all seasons at all
times in all weathers provided us within
the hours of operation it's no longer a
seasonal don't it's just a don't listen
to this permanent then I think the
answer is yes is a condition there four
hours of operation to meet the six Tests
of weather condition is acceptable one
of them is that it has to be necessary
in my view I don't think a condition
would be necessary because it would be
self placing the the Tennis Club
wouldn't pay to have the to keep them
inflated if they didn't really need it
therefore itself pacing therefore the
condition would not be necessary I agree
with that from a financial perspective
if they're going to make more money if
they've got more people playing during
the summer late into the night when it
starts getting dark so it no longer
becomes a temporary seasonal dome it
becomes a permanent all year round
though but operating in turn at certain
hours but we'll rush that is there any
way we can you are you asking it somehow
condition that it doesn't become a place
it says on the face of a temporary
seasonal dome it certainly becomes this
permanent all year round whenever the
hell we feel like dome I think the
Tennis Club is already in that position
in terms of who if it was owned when it
was dark they'd have the floodlights on
but they wouldn't necessarily need to
have it inflated unless it were raining
for instance those are the only
circumstances I could say that these
would improve the situation but no it's
a fair point that they may actually make
more money than it would spend on having
them inflated because it's nice
warm inside the dome I imagine not when
it's just floodlit yes you know is it
are we but if are we just saying you can
only use this between you know autumn
and winter months
or are we saying it's all year-round
because at the moment from what I'm
gathering from our recommendation it's
all year-round it's not temporary as
it's recommended officers would would do
the under delegated authority but if as
members you'd like to steer the
discussion of that condition then that's
something that you could do if there are
particular things that you want to
control that does okay when we can go to
that discussion character fielding I
play tennis at Toy Fair where we it is a
floodlit court which floodlights come on
obviously when it gets dark we've got
each corner and along with the sights
there double courts like similar to this
surely the having just two floodlights
is not going to be enough and my other
question is where is this dome going to
be stored and that because if they've
got to take it up every time it rains or
whatever it's going to be fairly
permanent in inclement weather to
address the first point on the foot
lighting there are more than two
floodlit and columns existing currently
on these courts it's just a case of the
two central that proposed to be
repositioned on a photo actually if I
can yeah there's more flood lighting
than the two that are being repositioned
essentially that in total so clear that
the reason for that is for the players
as you say to be able to you actually
use it for the reason I've got a
comeback coming then John how is the
dome going to cover those ones on the
boundary if they're the same height as
the ones in the middle it's a dome going
to be higher at the extremities I think
they're outside John have they shine in
through the outside they're outside and
they shine in that's also not really an
issue for us
you know it's a SAN issue for the Tennis
Club and okay no further questions
okay so just to help with when we get to
the debate have you've got details of
the hours of operation condition that
we've put on the existing domes because
if that's perfectly acceptable as far as
times and seasons and stuff then I'm it
might be we just you know there's no
hours of operation on the existing dome
that full-time permanent literally up
all the time they could yes if I see
them up quite a lot so yeah I presume
they are but I said I think they would
only use them where they facilitate I
understand is this the actual core is
this there was another photo you showed
of the core of the existing with the
dome up glorious sunshine in inclement
weather temporary seasonal or glorious
sunshine that's my concern
yeah yeah that's my concern so we'll
move to debate did you I have no
particular issue with with moving
forward with providers is that we are
actually conditioning that the whole
temporary seasonal operation with
obviously mr. boat on the existing and
we don't have something that we can copy
so as part of this the recommendation
with approved hours of operation I'd
like to be clear of the that's phones of
year as well and the inclement weather
for example the types of the times where
it's going to be put up because it I
want it to avoid not and when you guys
I'm sure you see you guys they're going
to be drafting this and seeing their
proposals from the applicants I want
that you guys to be very clear that this
is temporary and seasonal if they're
applying for then that's what we should
be looking at it permanent not temper in
season also just be very clear on that
when you come to it otherwise I have no
particular issue
I think we're going through a organ do
you anything just just want reassurance
that the description of the development
which is a temporary seasonal dome etc
etc during inclement weather that is
clearly in the recommendation because if
it is then I am reassured okay Barry my
view was to to see if it could be
restricted to the use of domes between
October and April so that it provides
winter tennis that to me is seasonal
September equinox till basically the
March
okay so we make the proposal that we
follow officers recommendation with
conditions on seasonality and timing to
be to be agreed with the chair if that's
okay yeah that's all in there actually I
quite like the idea of the okay so I
propose that with with that included
please okay so you're seconding that
yeah I proposed to you
are you happy officers with that as a
possible thing to do
I think we're looking for you know
reasons you know why we want you know
what why do we want to sign this
seasonality because that's what they've
applied for it's quite simple what's
been applied if they prefer something
permanent we've gotta have one people
talking you guys talk and can you put
yours off for a minute you've got to
bear in mind the time it takes to put it
up yep absolutely
okay we'll wait for the offices
okay that the term temporary is in the
description of the development that term
refers to the fact that they will go up
and down depending on the weather
but that inclement weather could be
during the summer that's why I'm
concerned about restricting summer usage
it's not clear from the application that
they want it for summer usage but it
does say to protect against implement
weather which could occur in the summer
as well so it does say temporary
seasonal don't sow season is yeah summer
spring or Dylan doesn't say which season
which is a bit ambiguous so we've made
that assumption it's any particular
season
therefore my suggestion would be the
clearly temporary in that they will go
up and down depending on the type of
weather and when they can be used not
nighttime because there's already flood
lights to cover that eventualities have
said so what we could do is go back to
the applicants to work up a wording no
actually yeah I think a condition
requiring the submission of powers of
terms of operation which we would then
come back to you chair with your
agreement to agree that so you can't
which is now without having to defer it
yes okay good good so the terms
operation I'm comfortable with but it's
clearly what we're trying we're seeking
to do as a committee is to make sure
that we are absolutely clear on when
this can can't be used so that when it
comes to an enforcement issue if they're
kept up 100% of the time we actually
have something worthwhile that we can
then say actually you know what you're
in breach that's the purpose and I'm
just really very clear about that
I think that's enforceable I suspect it
will be if it's raining or snowing or
whatever it may be that is when they're
justified in having that and that's
perfectly with that okay good so all in
favor of granting
with those conditions though he did good
thank you very much so we have resolved
to grant tithing application oh three
three three one
thank you very much